c'est l'essentiel tout ce bruit à chaque
instant même lorsque tout étant tout est
coupé
ça ne s'arrête pas et c'est même dans la
tête ça gêne comment je suis arrivé là à
quoi ressemblera demain est-ce que je
coucherais avec kim kardashian si je le
pouvais tellement de questions et tout
et tout ses bras
oui
arrête toi je dérange pas ouais je
tapais parce que j'ai décidé de partir
là je parle
du moins
il connaît ouais je venais pas à
katmandou
j'avais envie de partir loin et seul
m'échapper et croyez moi oh non j'ai
choisi katmandou parce que le nom
sonnait bien qu'attendue tu viens
katmandou tu fais ça tu te couches et
toi ou quoi katmandou et soyeux j'arrête
mais pour être très honnête c'est
peut-être pas meilleur endroit pour
échapper au bruit ça paye tout bas la
mort en fait loin c'est parce qu'il faut
ce qu'il faut c'est loin des autres
atteindre le silence j'ai rencontré
clément un français qui m'a expliqué
rappelant les bienfaits de la méditation
non c'est pas les voilà ses lutins
méditation en se concentrant sur le sofa
plus sur nos sensations ça permet de
renforcer dans votre faculté d'attention
et sortir de votre tendance naturelle à
l'attachement ou à la version se
détacher de ses désirs et ses versions
wii c'est peut-être ça ton j'ai besoin
et c'est ce que j'ai fais nous un peu
éloigné de la ville pendant une dizaine
de jours
c'était mon mentor mon souffle et moi la
mutation de 20 membres hui et je vivais
au rythme de ma respiration vraiment
horrible
espace une tribu de notre essai moto
news les vitriers passible de neuf trous
samedi soir
internet leur tour d'horizon m
une fois que c'était fini j'ai pu
commencer à découvrir une étape
à
ici
je suis même envie faire un film est en
marche en est ou non mais c'est un peu
galère vous cache pas
et durant tout ce temps je me suis
observé j'observais mes désirs mais
aversion à essayer d'être conscient plus
que je me suis d'habitude je me suis
installé chez une famille qui produit
son propre café
alors j'aime pas du tout le café mais
était super gentil et j'étais
complètement calme complètement serein
et cette sérénité se calme ça laisser de
la place à de l'amour l'amour non
intéressés l'amour d'une mère pour ses
enfants l'amour sans rien en retour
le bonheur est possible seul oui mais
lorsque l'on touche du doigt ce bonheur
imperturbable qui nous remplit et qu'on
brise notre ego alors nous ne faisons
qu'un avec le reste je n'existe plus
l'autre c'est moi
on oublie les chemins que l'on emprunte
n'oublie pas les gens surtout quand ils
ont failli nous coûter un drone et c'est
le chemin que nous a montrée plus de
2000 ont plutôt le grand siddharta
gautama qui après des années de pratique
devant le bouddha une fois réveillé il a
passé sa vie à essayer de transmettre ce
savoir aux autres plein de gratitude
tourné vers le monde puisque le soi
n'existe plus alors qu'on soit bien
d'accord je vous dis pas que je suis
heureux à jamais j'en suis très loin et
ses luttes lutte de tous les jours
ça demande un effort mais être autant de
jours dans le silence est observée
ça me permet de comprendre en tout cas à
quoi pouvait ressembler ce bonheur là
j'aurai l'occasion de vous en reparler
ne vous en faites pas je n'ai pas de
compte 30 millions d'habitants de
nombreuses religions avec des hindous
comme des bouddhistes qui prient les uns
à côté des autres
une situation politique extrêmement
compliquée qui a débouché sur un
gouvernement qui oublie sa population
pourtant grand besoin depuis le séisme
de 2015 il connaît de très gros
problèmes d'infrastructures et malgré
ses problèmes c'est un pays extrêmement
accueillants et méditation non je devais
une grande part de ma sérénité
je voulais les et des budgets m'a
expliqué l'un des problèmes qu'ils
rencontraient le plus souvent dans sa
vie de tous les jours et ça n'a rien à
voir avec le fait de ne pas avoir assez
de temps pour mater toutes les séries
qu'il est son netflix en me rappelant la
tête des panneaux électriques
ça ne m'a pas surpris et je vous parle
pas des panneaux solaires qu'on peut
voir un peu partout même dans des zones
assez rural d'ailleurs ça fait court un
message que mon père m'a envoyé quelques
jours plus tôt un jeune népalais qui
essayait de faire bouger les choses
du coup ça devenait évident
non
panique initiale et non à caser et népal
18 à 25 ans il élabore un appareil qui
l'a baptisé de négoce light qui alimente
aujourd'hui 500 foyers et qui a une
autonomie de 12 heures 12 heures de
lumière 12 heures pour pouvoir charger
ses outils de communication et reste en
contact avec le monde qui vous entoure
le mec a aussi construit un drone dans
plus grande est calme
que
son produit que très peu cher moins de
20 dollars malgré ce prix très faibles
made in re a besoin d'un coup de pouce
il a lancé une campagne ni gogo pour
pouvoir fabriquer distribuer 5000
panneaux et c'est de ça dont je vous
parlais c'est là qu'est mon utilité je
peux faire le pont entre made in draps
et vous alors je mets un lien vers sa
campagne mini coco et les gt line et si
vous les débats n'hésitez pas le népal
m'a fait un bien fou
j'espère lui faire un peu de bien aussi
et maintenant avant de rentrer j'étais
prêt pour un peu de bruit venant
il
à
jouer remercier chaleureusement tous
ceux qui me soutiennent sur tipi sans
quoi je n'aurais pas franchement eu
l'idée de faire une vidéo au népal en
tout cas avec des moyens bas comme brawn
par exemple vous avez fait la différence
et pour ça je ne dirai jamais assez
merci merci de soutenir mon compte
un grand merci aussi à cléon touchard
pour la musique on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler dans le making of qui sort la
semaine prochaine
soyez sûr de me suivre sur facebook
twitter et snapped la demande pas rater
les infos et d'ailleurs sur snapshot
vous avez été nombreux à me suivre en
direct au népal et c'est un plaisir de
partager les moments de ce couvercle
soyez heureux toutes et tous je vous
aime on sort la semaine prochaine
namasté
and you bad